all right about a million and a half
people visit the nation's capital every
March and April to see the cherry
blossoms in bloom
well now their natural beauty faces a
new threat which could cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to fix Jan Crawford
is at one of the most beautiful places
at this time of year it's the tidal
basin right there in our nation's
capitol in Washington DC June good
morning
well good morning Nora you know every
spring I mean this whole area is
transformed by nearly 4,000 cherry trees
in bloom they are so beautiful that
people come to see it from all over the
world but the crowds the erosion lack of
repairs is overwhelming and this
national treasure is now facing an
uncertain future most are here looking
up at these pastel peat petals but one
look down and their beauty is grounded
big holes mud and a walkway crumbling
under the weight of sinking earth rising
tides and too many tourists in search of
that perfect selfie cause it's not very
easy to walk here we saw people with
canes crutches and suitcases navigate
this rough patch right next to the water
now the National Park Service says it's
time for change and one mother whose
son's stroller got stuck agrees their
child's that weepy can fall there and
this is where the sidewalk ends at high
tide leaving not just people but these
century-old trees threatened you will
actually see that their roots are not
only compromised but actually exposed so
the Park Service and the National Trust
for Historic Preservation are turning to
the public for help
announcing a three-quarters of a million
dollars ideas lab a sort of shark tank
for the tidal basin this is not just
DC's calling parts of the nation its
America's calling card to the world it
is sinking and it is flooding and
there's over 500 million dollars in
deferred maintenance that needs to be
invested in this park so that it can be
saved for future generations now the
National Park Service estimates it will
cost 330 million dollars just to fix the
sea walls it's a concern for visitors
and quite frankly it's a kind
turn over ours we certainly share
people's frustration now some people are
calling for an even more dramatic
redesign of this whole body of water
right here behind me but that could cost
hundreds of millions of dollars and
we'll get a first look at some of these
ideas early next year John all right Jen
thank you so much
terrible FA we lost those